jeopardy years ago even though my
wardrobe outfit was the greatest choice
no no it doesn't matter everybody's
dress is very bad on that show
they're they're doing some uh some guest
hosting spots and it's going to be
released here pretty soon but
i have the opportunity to do one of
those
[Applause]
aaron rodgers telling pat mcafee earlier
today that he will be guest hosting
jeopardy they're in a tough spot with
that show who in the world is going to
follow alex trebek and they're working
their way through the final episodes now
before he passed to pancreatic cancer
recently i i i met maybe you just
permanently do guest hosts i don't think
anyone can do justice to that job the
way that alex trebek did it for so long
but it got us thinking
shireen matt borzello happy birthday
matt by the way he had a suggestion for
us to ponder
nfl players or figures past or present
that would make for a great jeopardy
host who comes to mind for you
well i started thinking about the
commercials mike and who's good in the
commercials there's no one better
in commercials we remember the saturday
night left night episode
with peyton manning i think peyton
manning easily is number one on this
list but if i'm going to pick a current
player
and i got myself in trouble earlier in
the year when i said baker mayfield was
better
had had more commercials than wins in
the nfl i
probably have to reel that back in now
but i would i would take baker mayfield
i think he's he's done a great job on
the commercials they're funny i enjoy
watching them i think it'd be fantastic
as a host of that show
you started talking about commercials
and i thought of the old miller lite
commercials with john madden
and john wouldn't john madden be awesome
yeah
he's the greatest of jeopardy he would
be great
i thought of gronk because it would be
fun to watch gronk trying to actually
read the clues holding the cards up to
his face
and asking for help on pronouncing
various names so there'd be a lot of
great colorful personalities that could
pull it off it's going to be a challenge
for aaron raj it's going to be a
challenge for anybody to do that job
because it's not as easy as it looks and
part of the greatness of alex trebek was
making it look as easy as he did
the good thing is it's not live so they
can have as many
takes and jump cuts as they need to try
to prop up
the performance of the host but could
you imagine someone trying to pull that
off live that would be almost impossible
to do all right let's answer some
questions at vamos
for ramos if big ben retires and deshawn
watson really wants out of houston
what about deshawn watts and shireen to
the pittsburgh steelers your reaction to
that
i think it'd be great for the steelers
but i don't see the texans doing that
you look at the two big trades they made
and that was sending deandre hopkins
they sent him to arizona and nfc team
and they sent dwayne
brown to seattle uh geneva and clowney
also went to seattle so
you know i don't think the texans are
are dumb enough
to trade deshaun watson but i don't
think they're dominant to traders
yeah that's exactly right so it's
not going to surprise me if they trade
him i will be surprised if they trade
him
to an afc team having said all that
when you look at the top of the draft
you want to pick that's higher than
steelers and when you look at the top of
the draft it's all afc
teams when you consider what the texans
are currently doing to try to repair the
relationship it shows me that they
are taking it seriously that they are
scrambling to try to repair it and they
know
it's untenable for them to proceed with
a quarterback who doesn't want to be
there
whether he withholds services or whether
he holds in where he just shows up and
says hey i just work here
i'm not showing up early i'm not staying
late i'm not going to be the leader of
the team
i'm not going to be part of management
i'm just a player like anybody else like
the long snapper the kicker the running
back the
the left guard that's all i am i either
way it's not
sustainable for the texans and the mere
fact that we're hearing
that eric the enemy is going to get
interviewed for the job
eventually tells me the texans are
trying to fix this because they know
they can't win
i had somebody suggest me over the
weekend that the texans should just play
hardball with him and say if you want to
sit go ahead and sit like mike brown did
with carson palmer 10 years ago it's not
going to work because he's not going to
cave
if he's decided he doesn't want to be
there and that's the thing these efforts
may be too late
if he's decided he doesn't want to be
there the steelers would make sense
if if they are the team that of the
teams that
desean watson will play for there's
going to be a subset of the other 31
teams that he'll say yes to
that's what you do if you're the texans
you figure out from deshaun watson
who are the the teams you'll play for
and then you have an auction
of those teams and you drive up the
price as high as you can and that's how
it
how it would play out and if you have a
top 10 pick
and you're one of the teams desean
watson will play for you're more likely
to be the team that desean watson lands
with and you're right sheree not having
a top 10 pick will make it harder for
the steelers to win that auction if it
comes to it
i i you know some of these twitter
handles i can't quite make out
in quiedici i think is how you would
pronounce this if it were actually a
word
is matthew stafford a better deal
overall for a quarterback needy
contender
than desean watson you don't have to
give up the farm for him and you'd get a
good slung your
gunslinger for at least five years
washington maybe
first question with matthew stafford is
what does he want what does the new
regime in detroit want it's premature
for now it could be
that the new group that comes in says we
love matthew stafford and it could be
that matthew stafford says
we lo i love this new regime i have a
feeling that's not where it's going to
land
but shireen a compelling potential
franchise quarterback
a guy who's had not much success because
of the team around him
could he be the answer for someone and
could he be a better option than deshaun
watson
i don't know if he's a better answer
than deshawn watson but he certainly
would take
less than compensation than deshawn
watson would
i think desean watson is a better
quarterback but matthew stafford
you know i think he's serviceable i
think he's probably better with where he
is in his career than philip rivers is
and so you look at a team like indy
that's ready to win now that went out
and got
philip rivers as a bridge quarterback
maybe
matthew stafford is the answer in indy
or a place like that that is ready to
win now washington
was mentioned that that's a place that's
obviously ready to win now if they've
decided that any of these quarterbacks
aren't their quarterback the future he'd
be a perfect fit there i think he can
win somewhere that's
that's a team that has a good defense
and a good running game mike in a good
offensive line
injuries to me still are a question with
him though he's he's been banged up in
his career
well and and here's how i look at it the
something's not right
with the body of work the experience the
12 years for or 11 years for matthew
stafford in detroit
and i i boil it down to this
i if
if he wasn't okay with this dysfunction
that's permeated his time with the team
he should have gotten out by now there's
just some defect there i'm having a hard
time articulating but my point is this
if this was peyton manning who had been
mired in all this dysfunction in detroit
he would have done something about it to
either make it better or get the hell
out of there if it was tom brady he
would have done something to make it
better or get the hell out of there
matthew stafford has done nothing to
make it better or get the hell out of
there
between 2009 and today so some of this
is on him
shireen i don't know if it's content to
get
the money he's gotten or hey i just
throw footballs i don't care about
whether or not we win
there's something there that bugs me
that makes me think he's going to take
that attitude with him
to his next team and the next team
better have that leadership from
others in the locker room and the kind
of coach that can push the team through
because there's something missing about
matthew stafford the quarterback slash
leader am i wrong
no you're not wrong at all and in the
last couple years i've picked detroit as
a wild card playoff team because i
thought they were ready to take that
next step
i thought they were ready to contend at
least for a playoff spot if
not for more than that and they haven't
done that and that falls
mike squarely on the shoulders of the
quarterback whether it's injuries
whether it's making mistakes
whatever it is matthew stafford has not
gotten that team where it needs to go
and he's a big reason why they are where
they are which is what they're looking
for another head coach
he's a coach killer frankly with all the
coaches they've gone through because he
can't take that next step
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports